[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jerry dulac
he covers the steelers for the
pittsburgh post gazette hosts the
steelers radio network as well and kind
enough to join us
before he heads to camp i saw where ben
showed up clean-shaven-ish
and uh he had a shirt on that said
different there jerry so
um are you forced to then report on
write about how great ben looks now
well i will tell you dan that um despite
what people
think the last three or four years he
has come to camp
in wonderful shape you know he's had a
he's hired a nutritionist he's hired
trainer
he looks especially good now especially
trim
people forget he's a big man he's a six
foot five 250 pound guy
but i have to admit as well as he has
looked every year coming to camp he
looks
especially well and fit uh yesterday
certainly in that picture
is he the fourth best quarterback in his
own division
yeah i think that's a bunch of baloney
uh you know that's based on
um you know that that's just based on on
future possibilities
um you know but i mean ben's a proven
winner and
uh three super bowl appearances two
titles a number of playoff victories
um his numbers speak for themselves and
even last year dan i think
you know when you think they got off to
that 11-0 start he's coming off
major major elbow surgery and at one
point aft
after 11 weeks he's being talked about
an mvp candidate
forget about comeback player of the year
then he had that little slump and he had
a big second half in the indie game over
300 yards and three touchdowns
that uh snapped him out of that slump
and then after that uh
you know that terrible start uh against
the browns you know the bad snap on the
first play from scrimmage
you know in the second half again 330
yards three touchdowns made every throw
possible
um you know ben has still been okay yeah
he's 38 he's not the same guy he was
when he was 28.
but uh this idea that he's the fourth
best quarterback in the division
uh just based on future possibilities of
the young guys in the division
um to me as as a little far-fetched why
do you think there was some trepidation
it felt like maybe on the steelers part
of
is ben do they want him back and at what
price do you get him
is that a correct uh impression of of
what happened here
yeah absolutely and i will tell you that
uh ben actually thought that they were
um trying to make him make to force him
to make the decision for them um
i i was surprised on one hand
uh but not because they did eventually
do what i thought they would do
uh but um you know they knew they had to
do something with that salary cap hit
but wanting feeling that they were in
position to move on
from him uh with all the changes they
were making
or thought they were going to have to
make and as it turns out some of those
they didn't
i'm certainly not surprised that he's
back i expected that all along
but i have to admit that and i was a
little surprised that there was
some hesitation i always thought it
would be ben would go
out on ben's terms and nobody else's and
for a while it looked like
it looked like it wasn't going to be on
his terms
what did you make of their offseason in
pittsburgh
well the funny thing is is they thought
a lot of the changes were going to be on
offense and not on defense they thought
you know maybe ben was going to be gone
uh they knew they were going to move on
from james connor they thought juju
smith
uh schuster would be gone they knew
marquise pouncey was going to retire
and of course that happened and they did
move on from james connor but
the funny thing is is a lot of their
changes dan ended up being on defense
they lost three starters
um they kind of anticipated that that
might happen with bud dupree
and maybe even mike hilton but now you
throw in the retirement yesterday
of vince williams you know a guy that
they had released after the season
decided to bring back just to kind of
plug that hole for one more year
and then he retires on him so i think
their offense uh yeah there's a lot of
changes um you know they weren't
counting on david de castro
moving on from him that was injury
related
um so the changes on the offensive line
they kind of somewhat knew that was
going to happen but they didn't plan on
decastro
so some of those changes they counted on
some they didn't i think they're better
offensively
i think they're a little a little less
ferocious on defense
let me get a quick hit on the other
teams in the division let's start with
the bengals
what do you expect well until they
show that they can move up to be a 500
ball club um you know i'll wait and see
it's kind of like the browns two years
ago the browns had to show me they could
do it again
and they did um but i mean i like joe
burrow um i think he's going to be a
fantastic quarterback i hated to see the
injury last year you hate to see that
happen to any kind of promising young
star i think they'll be better
but i mean i think the browns are legit
and the ravens are the ravens the ravens
are very much like the steelers even
when you don't think they're going to be
very good
they're good that's just that's a salute
to their organization
um but there's no reason to think look
i'm not going to sit here and pronounce
the steelers are going to the super bowl
but as i tell everybody dan i mean who
would have thought they'd start 11-0
last year
who thought they'd go 12-4 and win a
division i could tell you
not too many people certainly around
here um and
my feeling has always been as long as
you have number seven you're not out of
any game and you're not out of any
season
jerry great to talk to you and hopefully
we'll catch up with you during the
season we appreciate your time
yeah dan anytime good to chat with you
all right jerry dulac he covers the
steelers
pittsburgh post gazette hosts the host
on the steelers radio network